creepily smell some baby clothing and
put on appropriate Beach attire because
it's time to strap ourselves in for
another episode of American Horror Story
in this video we take a deep dive into
all the theories unanswered questions
and WTF moments of the show in the hopes
of figuring out what's really going on
as always I've left timestamps below so
you can see all the topics I'll be
covering but before we begin make sure
to like And subscribe I have a few
winefield gift baskets I need to send to
my pregnant friends is it just me or do
you also get creep vibes from Kamal when
Anna is driven home from the miscarriage
there are these shots of him just
watching her is he really there to keep
her safe or is it more to keep an eye on
her remember he's hired by Talia so
that's where his Allegiance lies the
dude also has access to the security
cameras all around the house and I'd
feel uncomfortable with him watching me
24/7 then there's Nicolet talia's
supposed house manager Anna and Dex came
to this place to be alone yet it seems
anyone can just just come willy-nilly
into their home there are a few
interesting things about Nicollet to
remember first no one besides Anna has
interacted with her meaning it's
possible she could be a figment of
Anna's imagination the same goes with
the drugstore worker at the end of the
episode who feels her baby kick nikolet
also has what Anna wants a baby a little
girl named Mary is it just a coincidence
then that last episode we saw an article
about Queen Mary making a deal with
infernal powers to secure her place on
the throne nicholet mentions that she is
a single mother convenient and with her
being the house manager do you think she
knows about the creepy passageway
underneath the house I mean let's be
honest it's not that hidden I would not
be surprised if nicolet's child was
conceived in that creepy basement by
those two blackd dressed women with
goats after all when Anna walks down the
hallway she'll see this smear of Blood
on the wall someone else has been here
before her we really don't know who
these women are they follow Anna on the
beach and are accompanied by two black
goats black goats often symbolize Satan
could these two have been the ones to
plant Anna's summerday doll with all the
pins in its stomach when Anna makes it
to the basement we'll see this Latin
phrase smeared in blood which translates
to hello oh boy hail Satan long live the
children of Our Lord combine this with a
collection of fetuses I think it's safe
to say these women are up to no good
they end up injecting Anna with
something that either a puts in some
sort of new baby or B resurrects the
Dead one inside of her it's only after
this event that she starts to feel the
baby again last episode we saw nurse Ivy
perform an ultrasound which then caused
Anna to miscarry she like Anna has this
pimple on her chin which suggests she is
either pregnant herself or was pregnant
by the very same people that Anna was if
Anna is indeed inseminated by the devil
and Ivy knows about this she'd
definitely want to do everything in her
power to prevent Anna from having this
child hence the don't do it Anna mirror
Anna says the detectives won't find any
security footage of Ivy which calls into
question whether Ivy is even real early
in the episode Anna takes a walk through
the forest and comes across an odd sight
there's a fire and Miss preacher singing
Rocka by baby in a tree she says she's
been looking for Anna when Dex Kamal and
Anna Venture back to the forest they
find there's no signs of fire at all and
a mysterious white owl is now perched
where preacher used to be the white owl
could be the symbolic opposite of the
black goat white owls often symbolize
Purity innocence and wisdom which could
mean preacher is one of the good guys
merely trying to warn Anna of what could
happen to her we know Miss preacher is a
real person both an assistant at the
fertility clinic and Kamal have had
interactions with her oddly enough when
Anna goes to check on Miss preacher's
Instagram accounts it looks like
preacher speaks and annihilate Anna have
been deleted near the end of the episode
we'll see preacher tell Anna watch out
for her it's implying preacher is
talking about Sonia shawcross who we saw
moments earlier Sonia shawcross the
woman who looks suspiciously like
Dexter's ex and who had an art show in
episode one has made it to the Hamptons
this shouldn't come as a surprise to
Anna as Dex mentioned her in episode 2
that Sonia would be in town to do a
popup show Sonia also very clearly sees
Anna and isn't surprised by her at all
nor does she wave hello which I thought
was weird we'll also notice Sonia's
trademark spiky shoes she B these at the
art show but Anna also saw them in the
women's washroom the night she and Dex
went out to dinner with Talia that's a
mystery that remains to be solved Anna
continues to have these large chunks of
time that she can't account for hell in
episode 2 she has almost two weeks go by
that she doesn't remember in this
episode we'll see her stumble into the
forest and forget how long she was there
and also black out before meeting
Siobhan there's also a number of times
that Anna is sedated without her consent
Dex tells her that after her miscarriage
she was sedated something she has no
recollection of and last episode we saw
how she was sedated at the award show
what if anything is done to her during
these times she can't recollect remember
that Anna is on all sorts of drugs and
pills the show makes a conscious effort
to put her quote unquote vitamins on
full display and we still haven't found
out if Siobhan's b12 vitamins are really
B12 in odd addition to the house was a
gift basket sent to Anna by the director
of her film The Ure this is from heish
who we met at the award show but just
how exactly did he get her location only
Dex and Anna know where they are and
Siobhan wouldn't give out their location
without permission also Siobhan hates
heish it's pretty weird that he'd send a
basket with wine in it to a pregnant
woman remember at this time he wouldn't
know she miscarried this basket also has
an apple in it symbolic for it being the
fruit the serpent or devil tried to give
Eve to eat in the Garden of Eden the one
fruit she was forbidden from eating
we've already seen serpent imagery
throughout the show and guess who tempts
her to eat eat the fruit
here I'm a bite it I've said from day
one there's something no good about this
deck I also have a sneaking suspicion
that HH is stalking Anna and that's how
he got the address for her basket this
would be a separate stalker than the
person who broke into Anna's apartment
in episode one heish is a guy who would
have worked closely with Anna for
several months and the first thing he
asks her at the gala is how does your
wife keep getting hotter mention he
inquires about her stalker situation I
get bad vibes from this guy for sure
Siobhan has been a great friend to Anna
which for me always raises a red flag
it's often the ones who are the most
helpful to the protagonist that end up
being the secret villain in the end
there's not a lot of updates I have for
her this episode she once again brings
up her miscarriage gets Anna on a cover
of Vogue and I couldn't help but notice
she's all dressed in black black seems
to be very common for pretty much every
character except Anna and we also see
Sonia and nicholet wear it this episode
too near the end of the episode Anna
changes her phone back to her old
password Dex 2020 she previously changed
it in episode 1 when someone was
rearranging appointments in her calendar
but the odd thing is this mysterious
texter was still able to contact her
after that so why she changed her
password back here I'm not really sure
wers contacting her informs her that her
baby isn't dead no one besides Anna and
the drugstore lady knows this it's
possible it could be Nicolet who saw
that Anna was bleeding from her gums an
early sign of pregnancy but I wouldn't
be surprised if it was Miss preacher
preacher is always on her phone and
seems to have much deeper knowledge on
what exactly is going on but now I turn
it over to you I want to hear your
thoughts and theories in the comments
below thanks for watching please be sure
to like And subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at thinkstory YT until next
time remember Daddy loves you very
much
[Music]